impact 1 50 m
quand
de la triste responsabilité de vous
annoncer le décès de huit personnes
devant la juge véronique pire tu lâches
pas assassiné par de véritables
prédateurs
[Musique]
pourquoi tu as fais à rien d'avoir
raison qui va produire 30 ans sur
terrain plat lequel je peux faire entrer
en flotte
on a perdu falcon et mon avis les
gallois n'ont pas fait ce qu'il veut
nous faire croire
je le serai pas qu il soit sur le dos
alors c'est quoi tout ça meurt et disent
que c'est faux c'était comment
l'histoire un truc qui plage dans la
verra lequel la bande des tueurs fous
985 on a affaire à des gens infiltré
dans toutes les sphères de l'état
nous avons toutes les preuves monsieur
ministre regardez son tatouage c'est
l'alcool
ça fait longtemps que je cours après
maintenant je peux rien
brutus pour inquiéter plus d'un
formateur pour dénoncer faut bien
admettre que quelqu'un j'ai à merveille
pour brouiller les pistes
[Musique]